et on pour une émission spéciale
consacrée à l' orléans loiret basket sur
france 3 centre on est très heureux
ça faisait longtemps que vous voulez
vous proposer cette émission sur
l'orléans loiret basket
à l'occasion des 20 ans du club alors
vous le voyez on s'est installé juste à
côté du parquet du palais des sports
il est en ce moment même un match
opposant le mans à orléans un match dans
la catégorie espoir on va vous en
reparler bien sûr dans quelques instants
les avant ça je vous propose de
découvrir le contenu de cette émission
spéciale consacrée alors léo loiret
basket on va parler de la formidable
épopée olb en 20 ans le club a connu
trois montées de la nationale 2 à la pro
a
nous reviendrons bien sûr sur les quatre
finales perdues mais surtout sur 7
elle a gagné en coupe de france en 2010
était à l'époque et laurent sciarra et
un cedrick banks et plus on parlera de
l'équipe actuelle brian greene qu'à une
mcalarney sans oublier bien sûr tous
ceux qui font le club au quotidien
bénévoles jeunes en formation supporters
on les entend et bien sûr dirigeants
voilà pour le programme
à quelques mètres de moi à quelques
mètres de ce plateau pour vous faire
vivre cette émission en direct arnaud
moreau aux côtés des graines de
champions de demain bonjour ardo oui
bonjour benoît et comme vous l'avez dit
derrière nous se déroule match le match
des espoirs entre orléans et le mans est
en fait chaque équipe du championnat de
france dispose d'une section espoir et
toutes les équipes s'affrontent
et c'est dans ce genre de match que les
recruteurs viennent voir qui seront les
futurs champions de demain les futurs
joueurs qui composeront la la pro a
française et qui vendent la première
division française
on parlera tout ça avec l'entraîneur des
espoirs stéphane bâti à la mi temps il y
aura plein d'autres surprises tout au
long de cette émission et on devra tous
ensemble noir tout au long de ce match
on va bien en profiter arlon merci à mes
côtés sur ce plateau
mes deux premiers invités françois
perronnet c'est l'entraîneur de l'équipe
première l'équipe de proa bonjour
françois bonjour merci d'être avec nous
et puis l'enfant du club un des enfants
du club
maël lebrun bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous
messieurs j'avais on avait tous ensemble
envie de débuter cette émission avec la
victoire de la semaine dernière
elle est importante cette histoire
remportés à wohlen sur mer avec l'équipe
de proies votre toute première victoire
françois c'est effectivement la première
victoire du groupe de cette année après
un début de saison un petit peu perturbé
l'équipe a su montrer un visage de
solidarité et d'engagement qui lui a
permis de faire un bon résultat à succès
grâce à une bonne défense
pas seulement on a joué on a joué face à
un adversaire qui a de très très grosses
qualités offensives qui joue de très
nombreuses possession le travail
défensif a été a été intéressant
mais l'équipe a aussi su trouver de
l'adresse ce qui lui a permis de pouvoir
battre bologne
un succès qui fait surtout du bien après
les deux défaites face à pau et
strasbourg 2 défaites en raison
notamment des nombreuses blessures que
vous connaissez leur groupe
effectivement nous nous vivons un début
de saison perturbé par des blessures
mais c'est le lot de toutes les équipes
il faut pas que l'on se retranche
derrière ça strasbourg était un
adversaire qui était hors hors de notre
ressort de notre niveau
par contre on aurait pu mieux faire même
avec les blessures et donc il faut il
faut il faut pas se retrancher derrière
ça
à nous d'être capables de faire mieux
quand une occasion se présente
belle en ce moment vous ne jouez pas
c'est une période très difficile pour
vous vous revenez de blessure
comment vous vivez cette période c'est
pas c'est pas facile il ya beaucoup de
frustration
je ne fais pas les délais déplacement
avec le groupe mais je suis quand même
les matchs derrière mon derrière mon
argument l'écran d'ordinateur et c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de frustration
quand on quand on voit comment se
déroulent les matches c'est pas c'est
pas facile c'est les défaites pour le
groupe malgré tout je fais partie du
monde quand même donc là des faits plus
la frustration la blessure c'est ça
c'est beaucoup à gérer pour autant
l'ambiance au sein du groupe vous la
vivez pleinement au quotidien oui tout à
fait tous les jours chez je vis avec le
groupe
le groupe fait de son mieux pour me
garder intégré à a commencé leur
entraînement tous les jours ils sont
l'âme encouragé dans ma rééducation un
pouce et donc
donc oui quand même je lis je dis tous
les jours avec le groupe alors ce groupe
pro une douzaine de joueurs avec un ou
deux issus du centre de formation
eh bien il ya des personnalités dans ce
groupe et notamment deux américains deux
joueurs emblématiques et kyle mcalarney
arnaud moreau et grégoire gré choix sont
allés passer du temps avec eux après les
entraînements regarder le palais des
sports d'orléans
ils le connaissent comme leur poche kyle
mcalarney 27 ans et brian greene 33 ans
sont deux joueurs emblématiques de l'ol
bc2 américains sont à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez eux mais ils sont ici
comme à la maison
kyle mcalarney vient de new york la
ville qui ne dort jamais mais son mode
de vie est plus tranquille ici rien de
tel que de rentrer chez soi le midi et
côté nourriture
il change petit à petit ses habitudes
c'est un sandwich franglais mais oui
nous aimons la nourriture française
et nous aimons essayé différents
restaurants kyle c'est l'anti-star un
joueur modèle réservé concentré et
impliquer aussi bien sur le terrain que
dans la vie cahill est un bosseur
quelqu'un de très impliqué peu importe
ce qu'il fait même pour notre mariage
c'est un homme super il se donne
toujours à 100 10 % sur le terrain ou
dans notre vie de couple les joueurs
simples loin des clichés grande gueule
et bling bling du basket c'est aussi le
cas de brian greene ce père de quatre
enfants entame sa cinquième saison à
orléans rare dans ce milieu où l'on
change parfois de club chaque année pour
plus d'argent
être à l'aise être heureux ça vaut un
sacrifice de quelques euros sur le
salaire j'ai eu la chance de faire une
belle carrière et de ma vie brian greene
aura donc marqué de son empreinte la
jeune vie du club
il ya des clubs qui existe depuis 100
ans et on oublie ceux qui y ont joué
être dans ce club si jeune c'est
excitant ça me fait plaisir d'en faire
partie constat partagé par kyle il se
sent chez lui à orléans et ce qu'ils
apprécient c'est le rapport familiale
avec le public comme sur les réseaux
sociaux
personne ne lui met la pression c'est à
lui de rester concentré mais pour moi la
vie et le basket c'est une question
d'équilibré
il faut rester calme et confiant quoi
qu'il arrive à flaine normal même si la
pression est fort il faut rester le même
qu'on perde ou qu'on gagne qu'at il
s'apprête à passer deux saisons au club
quant à brian dont c'est la dernière
année il espère rester et finir sa
carrière à orléans et justement arnaud
vous êtes je crois aux côtés d'un
besogneux le new yorkais kyle mcalarney
qui vient toujours en avance aux
entraînements parait-il
oui tout à fait benoît alors là vous
voyez c'est la mascotte qui est prêt
nous nous sommes avec kylie nous fait
l'amitié de il va essayer de répondre en
français alors kyle comment vous trouvé
l'ambiance à orléans c'est une ambiance
familiale explique henno oui
on s'ennuie on sait très bien le club
c'est comme un petit familles de la
ville
c'est cette très belle mon fait mais moi
il faisait bon kai vous êtes un très
gros travailleur vous avez une
pourcentage de réussite à trois points
qui est à peu près de 43%
vous êtes à 13 points de moyenne des
statiques vous êtes assez régulier
quel est votre secret vous vous
entraînez avant l'entraînement je crois
vous tirer avant l'entraînement
expliquez nous ce n est pas en sécurité
a love basque bon abri jeu pourra pas
être bon pour avoir du succès il faut
travailler dur et pour moi je ne suis
pas le jeu le plus grand ou le plus
rapide
soc c'est très important pour moi
d'accord donc c'est important pour lui
de travailler beaucoup car votre votre
votre spécialité c'est quoi c'est le tir
à l'extérieur qu'est-ce que vous qu'est
ce que vous préférez faire sur le
terrain oui bien sûr
je peux faire c'est maman ne m'a pas
cinq à douma basque à brive en de bosses
donc sa spécialité c'est le tir
extérieur et benoît donc il s'entraîne
très dur pour ça il espère être le
meilleur
merci qui merci beaucoup merci
fauconnière de france wasquehal c'est un
joueur important dans votre dispositif
oui parce que il est une menace dans le
tir extérieur régulière il a aussi
aujourd'hui une expérience du basket
européen qui lui permet de maîtriser un
grand nombre de situations et à ce titre
il est comme d'autres un joueur intense
en duo il ya une statistique 84 tirs à
trois points réussis en pro à l'an passé
c'est tout simplement le recordman ou si
vous saviez non pas du tout je regarde
très peu ce style de deux statistiques
vous occuper du groupe et c'est bien
normal
mike hayes c'est l'équipier modèle oui
enfin un modèle par rapport à au fait
que c'est vrai que c'est un vrai
travailleur que ce soit pour moi ou pour
les plus jeunes sont des formations ne
voient toujours arrivé une demi heure
trois quarts d'heure avant tout le monde
à la salle
il part après tout le monde et
s'entraîne avant ils s'entraînent après
les entraînements et c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de répétitions dans ses
gestuelles pour justement pour pouvoir
atteindre ce taux de réussite les
pouvoir être adroit comme ça alors
chaque année à l'aube de la saison
tournoi de préparation et journée
d'intégration sont organisées par le
club journée auquel ont pu assister
christelle schatt le teint avec fanny
boutiller apprentissage de l' escalade
pour des basketteurs professionnels la
journée d'intégration de l'ulb une
tradition c'est important de le faire
quelque chose qui soit en dehors du
basket et en dehors de la préparation je
dirais très près ce qu'on a tous les
jours
merci bonjour
on a fait vraiment le vertige c'est bon
j'ai pas regardé des trois enfants
encore découverte d'une nouvelle
activité sportive pour de nouvelles
sensations
forcément ça fait un peu peur au départ
mais après quand on monte on voit que
c'est un peu amusant et mais quand on
arrive en haut si on regarde en bas ça
fait peur ce genre
à 30 ans c'est l'occasion pour nous nous
met dans des situations qui sont
inhabituelles est intéressant de
regarder un petit peu comment les les
gens réagissent avant l'entraîneur doit
de montrer l'exemple c'est fait il faut
essayer de montrer l'exemple
effectivement travailler le collectif
sur le terrain comme au pied du mur
développer l'esprit de groupe renforcer
la solidarité le tout dans la bonne
humeur toute la famille basket au sens
très large du terme est convié à la fête
c'est intéressant c'est pas le genre de
choses qu'on fait tous les jours c'est
plutôt difficile on utilise des parties
du corps qu'on ne sollicite pas au
basket mais c'est amusant
la pression à montech déferler faire les
choses comme j'aimerais les faire
progresser
c'est frustrant mais c'est toujours
moins frustrant que d'être sur le bord
du terrain en civil pendant que les
autres jouent donc voilà ta vie tu sais
c'est le cloud c'est le clown de service
hélas bien il a bien fait rigoler tout
le monde même si une fois sur le terrain
il est très très sérieux quand il faut
détendre l'atmosphère et s'est dit fier
et s'il fait rigoler j'ai séparé gaulle
et toute l'équipe boxer c'est important
il aime bien faire le il a bien fallu
aux sessions à chaque fois on essaye de
changer ou de trouver des thèmes
différents mais à chaque fois c'est
ludique et c'est un peu sur la rivalité
la compétition ce qui nous caractérise
tous
finalement
le sourire de brian greene on l'a vu
dans le sujet la fin là avec son bébé
dans les bras c'est aussi ça cette
journée c'est une journée familiale
alors qu'on siffle la mi temps de la
rencontre entre les espoirs
oui c'est ça c'est l'intérêt de ce type
de journée c'est de mettre les joueurs
en situation différente de celle qu'ils
ont sur le terrain de basket c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire partager à leurs
familles ce moment-là et de partager et
de se découvrir au travers d'activités
plutôt ludique belle de vie de noël
c'est le clown de service du groupe l'un
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un de très
sérieux et très impliqué au niveau
basket mais c'est vrai que j'ai souvent
là à faire le clown et a fait rigoler
quand il y en a besoin et c'est vrai que
c'est important au sein d'une équipe
vous savez pas été trop frustré de ne
pas faire d' escalade
je suis pas trop trop escalade mais
maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
frustrant dans le sens où on peut pas
j'étais présent mais je suis partagé
parce que les ce que les autres vivaient
entre eux je pourrais pas pas réellement
le partager quoi donc c'est en avril
dernier vous avez connu le pire pour un
joueur professionnel c'est la rupture
d'un tendon d'achille enfin une blessure
grave
j'entends par là comment vous avez vécu
la suite de cette blessure de l'été
notamment
ça a été beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
rééducation passage par le centre de
rééducation de capbreton
après j'ai travaillé pendant un mois
avec un kiné s'est passé beaucoup
beaucoup travailler pour pouvoir revenir
en forme quand quand je pourrai revenir
vu que je peux encore beaucoup de
travail pour pouvoir revenir en forme je
serais sûrement pas à 100 % des moyens
dès le début mais revenir le mieux
possible
il ya une date de retour prévue pour
maël et qu'il le pourra mais qu'il le
pourra merci beaucoup françois d'avoir
été avec nous en début d'émission lebel
le bras vous restez avec nous parce
qu'on va parler de quelque chose que
vous connaissez bien le centre
d'information dans quelques instants au
centre de formation où vous êtes issue
mais avant cela on évoque la préparation
physique avec arnaud moreau vous êtes en
bonne compagnie je crois oui tout à fait
benoît je suis avec nordine adapter le
préparateur physique du club alors on
vient de parler de la blessure de mails
c'est vrai que c'est c'est
malheureusement de ces des pépins qui
arrivent en cours de saison lors d'une
fois qu on vous connaît parce que vous
intervenez sur le magazine de la santé
là ce que vous dit aux joueurs qu'on
voyait rien nous c'est que leur corps
c'est leur outil de travail c'est ce que
vaut leur dit exactement et c'est
vraiment un ensemble de paramètres
tu vas faire qui vont pouvoir suivre la
saison d'une façon optimale au niveau
physique
et pour ça c'est pas juste être grand
c'est aussi avoir une musculature
équilibrée de la souplesse une notion de
vitesse et d'endurance
est-ce qu'on est conscient à cet âge là
quand on est un jeune basketteur est ce
qu'on est conscient des limites de son
corps ou est ce qu'on veut toujours les
dépasser non est malheureusement plus
avec ce soit des magazines ou des vidéos
qu'on peut voir sur facebook
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le joueur veut
aller très très vite
avant même d'intégrer la notion de
préparation physique il faudrait qu'ils
intègrent cet océan de plus de formation
physique le alors j'imagine qu'à une
difficulté pour vous c'est que vous
devez tout de suite détecté un mal dire
que pour pour quelqu'un qui va faire du
basket assez peu régulièrement bon bah
si on le ressent une douleur ces
patriotes mais vous devez tout de suite
être capable de dire assez tel
diagnostic c'est telle chose alors alors
après mois au niveau 2 au niveau du
recrutement on va participer mais c'est
un ensemble avec le kiné avec les coachs
et si c'est moi sur la partie physique
qui doit permettre de déterminer si le
joueur est apte ou pas à évoluer à un
haut niveau comme ça il faut avoir des
qualités de souplesse ici l'explosivité
de weert et qui déplut verticalité et
d'endurance notamment eh bien merci et
merci dans l'es2 merci bonne saison et
les jeunes que l'on va derrière nous
sont tous issus du chantre de formation
un centre de formation qui comprend une
vingtaine de jeunes qui viennent de
toute la france
alain eudes a suivi l'un d'entre eux je
vous propose de voir tout de suite ce
reportage l'anglais ce n'est pas la
matière de prédilection de nathan mais
pandy à tout juste 16 ans ce jeune
basketteur originaire de melun est
inscrit en seconde bac pro
électrotechnique une orientation un peu
contrainte après un redoublement en
troisième
moi c'est toujours le basket qui
m'intéresse mais je consulte si par
exemple il m'arrive oublie surtout sa
faune faut avoir un un diplôme à l'école
mais là j'essaye de faire de mon mieux
d'apprendre les leçons là j'ai du temps
moi j'essaie quand même même si c'est
pas ce qui me plaît mais pour faire avec
les murs de sa chambre où les images
qu'ils visionnent n'évoque qu'un seul
centre d'intérêt
nathan vit par et pour le basket cet été
il est devenu champion d'europe avec
l'équipe de france des moins de 16 ans
et cette aventure a décuplé son envie de
devenir joueur professionnel
moi quand on a fait ça le déjà envie de
le refaire mais fois c'était un moment
inoubliable pense qu'on a fait est
incroyable et c'est sûr que pour un
basketteur humain on a encore envie d'en
faire un plein des comme ça ça veut dire
mais c'est notre objectif c'est mon
objectif son objectif france atomise
vivre de leur passion tutoyait le très
haut niveau du basket mondial
c'est un patrimoine commun à tous les
jeunes du centre de formation de l'ol b
ici on ne brise pas leur rêve mais on
leur inculque des notions de travail de
patience d'humilité et l'on exige
beaucoup car en offre beaucoup on est
peut-être un des seuls centres de
formation qui n'est pas payant on
demanderait en par an il ya même des
fois on va jusqu'à payer la la scolarité
l'alimentation va jusqu'à jusqu'au bout
du bout parce qu'on investit on fait de
l'éducation
l'homme qui permet à ces jeunes
d'intégrer le centre et le recruteur du
club david fernando ortega pour nathan
mais pandy comme pour tous les autres
l'entraîneur a appliqué le label olb un
filtre implacable
on aime les joueurs qui ont un niveau
athlétique parce qu'on est convaincu que
le haut niveau c'est d'abord des
qualités athlétiques
on a aussi des joueurs qui qui aiment
jouer à 5
parce que notre identité et notre
culture fait que on joue à saint que ce
soit défensivement ou collectivement
donc il faut qu'on a un mariage appelés
ticket et cérébrales plutôt intéressant
et la méthode fonctionne chaque année au
minimum un pensionnaire du centre signe
un contrat professionnel
nathan mais pandy a de grandes chances
d'être l'un des futurs gagnants de cette
loterie
alors nous sommes bien avoir un sujet
sur le centre de formation et nous
sommes avec stéphane pâtit bonjour vous
êtes entraîneur des espoirs
qu'est ce qui peut expliquer en deux
mots quelques purs présente ce
championnat espoir c'est une sorte de
vitrine du centre de formation ça peut
être ça peut amener des joueurs après à
se diriger vers des clubs professionnels
bonjour déjà la vocation du centre de
formation est très simple elle permet de
deux structures et des garçons pour
qu'ils puissent accéder à l'équipe
professionnelle donc elle est la vitrine
du centre de formation si on veut parce
que c'est l'équipe la plus avec les
joueurs les plus âgées du centre de
formation il ya des cadets en dessous
mais sa vocation première c'est surtout
d'amener des joueurs avec qui
professionnels t'imagines si important
pour des joueurs à ces jeunes d'avoir
une sorte de structure comme ça de sable
de voir comment comment fonctionne le
monde professionnel c'est important pour
eux tout ça de d'avoir dette assez
strictes au niveau de tout un tas de
règles
oui c'est ce qui est intéressant pour
eux c'est que le centre de formation il
fonctionne comme l'équipe
professionnelle que ce soit sur le
terrain ou en dehors un peu de choses
près et que ça leur donne un avant goût
de ce qui peut les attendre si jamais il
mérite d'accéder à ce niveau là et ils
sont déjà regardé à cet âge il ya déjà
des recruteurs qui viennent un peu voir
les potentiels des uns et des autres oui
sont regardés après les joueurs qui sont
dans les structures de santé formation
ils ont déjà été recrutés donc
aujourd'hui ils sont censés évoluer vers
l'équipe professionnelle du club
bonjour merci stéphane pas si bon
courage pour la deuxième mi temps et à
bientôt
merci arnaud de retour ici au palais des
sports pour vous faire vivre cette
émission spéciale consacrée à l'heure
les angloys et pascal basket et
christophe dupont son président nous a
rejoints bonjour christophe merci d'être
avec nous bonjour benoît on l'a vu dans
le reportage
avec stéphane pattier instant
l'importance d'avoir un centre de
formation au sein d'un club pro
aujourd'hui c'est indispensable j'ai
envie de dire c'est indispensable sur la
durée il est évident que un club comme
le nôtre ne peut pas exister si on n'a
pas un centre de formation performant et
et c'est très très clair que les autres
mais beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
d'efforts financiers aussi sur ce centre
de formation
après 10 ans d'existence ça fait dix ans
je crois quels sont les enseignements
que vous avez tiré les enseignements
c'est que au départ on a eu une période
de rodage une période d'apprentissage en
fait notamment avec stéphane qui est là
depuis le début du centre et puis au fur
et à mesure on a pu voir des bénéfices
mais les est un exemple
absolument quand par rapport à ça donc
et puis d'autres d'autres jeunes sont
sont issus du centre de formation et ça
c'est des éléments importants surtout
dans les moments de blessure ça coûte
combien le centre de formation
aujourd'hui environ 500 400 à 500 mille
euros c'est quoi ces 10% du budget ouais
c'est pratiquement 10% du budget c'est
un peu comme de la recherche
développement dans une entreprise une
industrie en fait vous êtes un pur
produit du centre de formation
vous êtes fier d'être un enfant du club
passé par cette formation
oui oui bien sûr que oui je suis fier à
la base
quand je suis arrivé ici je savais pas
du tout comment ça allait se passer pour
moi j'avais peur de la fin de la
première saison de qu'on décide pas me
rappeler du sud de la france
voilà c'est ça et j'avais peur qu'on
décide pas me garder mais en fait non ça
a très bien très bien fonctionné pour
moi et j'ai eu la chance à l'époque où
je suis arrivé ici la chance que ce soit
philippe hervé l'entraîneur pro ai
commencé en fait à amélie un peu les
entraînements pro est jeune il est il
faisait des interventions pendant les
entraînements cadets donc ça a été une
chance pour moi ça m'a servi par la
suite et donc oui mais non sera vraiment
été une chance pour moi de passer par le
son des formations vous avez un souvenir
particulier de ces années ça devait être
un peu aussi la franche camaraderie
ouais c'est on est tous plus ou moins
plus toujours plus ou moins frère dans
le dans le centre de formation quoi on a
une vraie une vraie solidarité
je veux pas dire qu'on a fait les 400
coups mais on a fait pas mal pas mal pas
mal de bêtises quand même voilà bompard
française attrapé par francis delattre a
fait c'est les risques mais non c'est
vrai que c'est des bons souvenirs ces
années merci j'ajoute que nathan mais
tandis que nous avons vu dans le sujet
dans la 1e de bain et n'a toujours pas
repris la compétition à vous l'avez vu
les blessés comme vous mais elle il ne
joue donc pas cette rencontre
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs c'est la
mi-temps entre orléans et le mans match
des espoirs et il y à 41 à 25 en faveur
de l'équipe visiteuse l'équipe du mans
merci beaucoup
maël d'avoir été avec nous on va
s'intéresser maintenant à l'histoire du
club on s'est intéressé à l'avenir avec
vous un petit peu même si maintenant
vous êtes bien intégré au centre à
l'équipe professionnelle mais on va
regarder en arrière
l'histoire du club vingt ans en vingt
ans les ans un tout connu le monde
amateur le monde pro changement de nom
changement de logo
la victoire en coupe de france quelques
défaites aussi une ascension fulgurante
on voit cela avec arnaud moreau
l'eau est élevé est un enfant qui a
grandi vite et bien en 20 ans le club a
connu trois montées deux titres il fait
désormais partie des dix meilleures
équipes françaises
et pourtant les débuts sont plutôt
modestes dans les années 90 le club
s'entraîne dans ce gymnase de saint jean
de braye qui vient à l'époque de
s'associer avec fleury les aubrais les
joueurs évoluent en nationale 2 4e
division française en 97
c'est autour d'orléans de fusionner avec
l'équipe qui deviendra l'entente
orléanaise
à l'époque les joueurs sont amateurs et
s'il faut retenir un nom ce sera celui
de flip peser à la fois joueur et
enseignants il passera onze ans au club
tout est réuni pour ça se passe bien
maintenant c'est pas une science exacte
et donc j'espère qu'à la fin de saison
on se reverra je vous dirais ben vous
voyez je vous l'avais dit que ça s'était
bien passé mais bon ça on verra bien
mais je pense que c'est vrai qui a
quitté réunies pour qu'on réussisse
il avait vu juste l'équipe gravi les
échelons petit à petit jusqu'à la pro b
équivalent de la deuxième division en
2002 en 2005 un entraîneur arrive en
cours de saison philippe hervé il ne le
sait pas encore mais il va devenir une
figure du club en récupérant un gros mal
en point il emmène ses joueurs deux fois
à bercy pour la finale de la coupe de
france perdue contre dijon puis une
autre finale victorieux cette fois ci
face à chalon l'oin b devient championne
de pro b et accède à l'élite
le club s'adapte bien à la proie et n'a
pas fini de monter grâce à ce joueur
arrivé en 2008
laurent sciarra vice-champion olympique
à sydney avec les bleus dès le début il
est clair moi je viens dans un but tous
nbc c'est aider le club sur le terrain
et en dehors du terrain voilà il faut
que nous on soit au niveau des ambitions
du club pour pouvoir prétendre à devenir
ce que j'espère pour le club d'ici d'ici
un an deux ans trois ans un club
important du chapeau intéressant dès la
première année le club en finale de
championnat à bercy mais échoue contre
villeurbanne
chacun son tour c'est en 2010 que
s'écrira la plus belle page du sport
collectif en laine l'entente a de
nouveau rendez vous à bercy
cette fois pour la finale de coupe de
france face à gravelines et l'équipe ne
flanche pas 73 69 score final ça valait
bien un accueil digne des fêtes
johanniques
même l'insaisissable philippe hervé et
ému une seule fois entendu un coup ci je
vais vous tous nous concernant philippe
hervé
l'homme qui aura marqué de son empreinte
la jeune histoire du club à son actif
deux titres et plusieurs qualification
en coupe d'europe
il a quitté le club cet été après neuf
ans de bons et loyaux services
christophe quand vous voyez toutes ces
images à quelle est celle qui vous a
marqué le plus haut là il ya beaucoup ce
qui me marque c'est ça me va chaque fois
j'ai toujours suis toujours ému par
rapport à ces images moi je pense que le
plus grande émotion que j'ai eu c'est le
soir d'un match de coupe d'europe de
rowling est en fait c'était le tournoi
préparatif qualificatif pour l'euro
league c'était le soir de benetton
c'était au zénith
on avait cinq mille personnes et ça a
été la victoire c'était pas une victoire
d'ailleurs c'était une défaite de deux
points qui nous a permis en fait le
qualifier en euroligue et là on touchait
les sommets européens et c'était un
moment d'extase et vous mail
moi je pense que ça a été vraiment la
victoire en coupe de france
même si en 2010 même si j ai pas
participé sur le terrain mais je faisais
partie du groupe je m'entraînais tous
les jours avec le groupe et et comment
ça a été mon meilleur souvenir parce que
justement le groupe leur offrir à tous
ses joueurs cédric qui font que ça
restera donc ça reste ma mémoire à cette
victoire en coupe de france était en
2010 face à gravelines est ce que vous
aviez joué quelques minutes du tout
semblé dire que vous avez joué quelques
minutes ce match et c'était enfin une
victoire après celle perdue
les deux semaines des as et puis après
aussi également là la défaite en
championnat de france en 2009 face à
c'était dur ça a été très très dur parce
que bon c'est là où je commence à avoir
quelques quelques minutes sur sur le
terrain avec le groupe pro et c'est vrai
que cette défaite à la semaine des as
elle était vraiment vraiment très dure
et dure à digérer et la défaite en
championnat de france face à l'asvel en
2009 c'était sur un match vous regrettez
saas est un bâtiment sur un match c'est
là on s'est rendu compte ce match on l'a
on est passé à côté et eu en fait en
plus un changement de joueur à l'asvel
qui a complètement déstabilisé philippe
le soir la veille au soir
en termes de en termes d'organisation de
jeu 1 et ça a été un peu compliqué
effectivement parce que on n'a pas aussi
bien profité que si on avait eu des
allers-retours comment on le fait
aujourd'hui en trois matchs gagnants
donc c'est sûr que je pense que à la
fois c'est intéressant parce qu'on n'en
mail 4000 personnes au à bercy et c'est
un moment de partage
extrêment bien avec nos supporters mais
à la fois ça aurait pu être intéressant
sur le plan plus sportif parce que je
pense que cette année là on était
capable de d'aller plus loin et depuis
ses revenus à trois matches la finale
trois matchs gagnants michel aliot faire
cinq matches en fait entre les allers
retours c'est vraiment le meilleur qui
gagne finalement j'ai envie de dire à la
fin ouais c'est je pense une opinion
c'est un très très bon une très bonne
formule et en plus maintenant les demi
finales sont aussi en cinq matches en
trois matchs gagnants donc ça peut être
cinq matches et c'est vraiment très très
bien on l'a vu cette année d'ailleurs le
lb au plus haut niveau c'est grâce à un
joueur en particulier laurent gerra oh
oui oui je pense que laurent au moment
où il arrivait moi je me souviens de sa
conférence de presse c'était
au sud d'orléans et dans les couloirs je
n'étais pas président ce moment là mais
je participais effectivement activement
j'étais vice président du club et je lui
ai dit en partant j écoute laurent on se
connaît pas mais j'ai le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui on va passer un cap
réellement et il nous a fait passer un
cap c'est énorme
on peut le dire c'est un gros coup que
vous avez réalisé avec philippe hervé à
l'époque oui ben c'était effectivement
très intéressant parce que laurent c'est
très déterminés pour pouvoir étaient
déterminés pour pouvoir nous faire
grandir aussi avec philippe et le couple
philippe et laurent ça a été on a vu ce
que ça a pu donner un c4 4 finales sur
six avec une victoire en coupe de france
et les actionnaires florent serra resté
deux saisons à l'ol b entre 2008 et 2010
capitaine vainqueur de la coupe de
france en 2010 donc et puis il avait été
élu mais un joueur du all star game en
2008 alors qu'il jouait avec orléans bat
l vous avez vous êtes fier d'avoir joué
à ses côtés d'avoir connu un vice
champion olympique russe et c'est
vraiment une fierté pour moi ça m'a
apporté beaucoup je pense dans la suite
de mon basket parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a beaucoup d'expérience dans le
monde de basket mais même dans le monde
de la vie en général
ça a été vraiment un vraiment un modèle
pour moi et je me suis beaucoup servi de
comment il était pour pour être comme je
suis aujourd'hui un autre joueur très
apprécié du public sur cette période
cédric banks on va le voir à l'image
il est revenu entre temps orléans mais
c'était moins pour les prolifiques
il a apporté quand même beaucoup à
cédric à chacun tous les matins en
termes de résultats joui au niveau du
résultat global de l'équipe
effectivement ça a été fait est moins
intéressant mais c'est une année quand
même extradé en était troisième du
championnat de france est notre deuxième
meilleure saison après la saison 2009
2010 et
c'est avec ce groupe que le lb a disputé
ses premiers matches en coupe d'europe
notamment contre un club belge
spirou charleroi gens vont se souvenir
ben le déplacement à charleroi c'était
le premier match européen je me souviens
y avait le même le maire d'orléans et ça
tombe de partenaires qui étaient
présents et puis le retour au zénith
devant 5000 personnes là encore ça a été
des grands moments enfin venir c'est des
très bons souvenirs tout ça on peut pas
tous les citer mais d'autres joueurs ont
marqué cette période
ludovic vaty anthony dobbins justin
doellman aldo curti et puis adrien
moerman qui est à limoges aujourd'hui
champion de france et puis il ya un
homme
il faut en parler on est bien évidemment
philippe hervé l'artisan le créateur
c'est un grand un grand monsieur du
basket ça a été un grand monsieur
d'orléans loiret basket sans lui on
n'aurait pas pu faire tout ce qu'on a pu
faire et on a rendu hommage à l'afrique
lors de son dernier match lors de sa
dernière victoire à orléans
je crois qu'il y a
un maillot que l'on a décroché c'est pas
je crois j'en suis sûr on l'a décrochée
en fait au moment de son départ et je
crois que le public en lea n'est lui a
rendu
vraiment un hommage très émouvant très
très chargé d'émotion parce que philippe
on a vécu des moments inoubliables avec
lui dont que c'est un grand monsieur
on aurait aimé l'avoir aujourd'hui mais
il a complètement tourné la page trop
élevé je pense qu'il faut qu'ils
puissent tourner la page effectivement
et c'est un moyen aussi de je pense
qu'il va revenir en riant mais une fois
que une fois que les choses seront
seront un petit peu le deuil sera fait
en fait juste pour bien que nos
téléspectateurs se rendent compte
philippe hervé ces cinq finales avec los
élevé dont une finale en coupe de france
en 2010 cécile est exactement vice
champion de france en 2009 face à
l'asvel il a été également élu meilleur
entraîneur de pro a en 2009 avec l'ol b
on est le meilleur entraîneur de pro a
avec en 2009 parce que parce qu en fait
personne ne nous attendait à 7
à ce niveau là sur la saison 2008-2009
et on a fait une grande partie de la
saison devant l'asvel
et puis et puis on a on a fait la
semaine des as on a fait la finale du
championnat de france
et là c'était une croissance in oui
parce que ce mois on n'avait que 15 ans
au niveau du club et ça a été je crois
c'était après dépassé par nanterre parce
qu'ils sont devenus champions de france
on est juste après en terme de entame
d'évolution sportive la plus rapide de
france
alors oui laure confondues alors qui
connaît le mieux philippe et remix que
ses anciens joueurs ses anciens
collègues christelle schatt le torse et
elles et leur poser la question elle est
allée vous voir également maël lebrun
phillips et un talent responsable
énormément d'ambition et puis la
conviction fait la rencontre avec
philippe hervé c'est la capacité à
exprimer à un niveau supérieur à ce
concert il nous a fait grandir et c'est
quelqu'un effectivement qui compte pour
nous charismatique
charismatique simplement est là
c'est simplement quelqu'un qui sait de
quoi il parle
c'est pour moi si je devais définir je
définirais comme ça un grand-angle sur
le plan humain sur le plan sportif c'est
ces voix là vraiment c'est un grand
homme qui a accompli beaucoup de choses
et qui m'a permis de faire beaucoup de
choses aussi donc voilà j'ai beaucoup de
respect qu au louis
c'est mon ami mais je préfère qu'on
jouait produit à l'époque où j'étais
j'étais cadet il intervenait dans les
entraînements cadets et il avait déjà un
oeil sur moi cette période là il
intervenait déjà pour me donner des
conseils et ça jusqu'à jusqu'à la saison
dernière encore me rappelle la première
année on arrive ici on avait une équipe
difficile ou à y avait beaucoup de gros
caractères c'est impressionnant de voir
comment
pour moi il s'est remis en question par
rapport à l'équipe comme et s'est adapté
pour pouvoir nous coacher de la mer de
façon c'est pas tous les causses pas
faire ça moi je me souviens il ya les
autres qui s'est vu passer à une salle
en avant le match de coupe de france ou
en fait il avait oublié ses chaussettes
donc il faut équiper avec son avec ses
chaussures sans chaussettes et il a
fallu gérer chercher dans le magasin du
coin
une paire de chaussettes pour lui
permettre à fait de passer le match
correctement le soir du match contre
strasbourg où il est bloqué à
l'intérieur du parc pasteur en venant de
chez lui au palais des sports et où il
faut faire venir la police municipale
pour le délivrer c'est le soir aussi où
les qui son équipe va réaliser un score
historique et avoir un résultat
incroyable
un homme nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
qu'on va parler d'une autre époque à
présent mais moins connus mais tout
aussi fondatrice philippe heuzé bonjour
merci d'être avec nous à nos côtés
bonjour vous avez porté les couleurs de
relais en prenant 11 années oui c'est
vrai ça fait ça fait pas mal d'années
oui j'ai connu beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses au sein de ce club et je regarde
beaucoup de bons souvenirs
vous voyez le chemin parcouru vous dites
quoi vous qui avez quasiment on va voir
entrer dans le détail mais vous qui avez
quasiment tous connus que d'efforts
consentis que travail effectué et je
crois vraiment que j'ai vécu au travers
de ces années là montée dans le
professionnalisme est vraiment
maintenant c'est un club qui appartient
au gotha du sport 20 du basket français
c'est encore un club jeune mais c'est
bien installé alors vous avez été un des
artisans des différentes montées depuis
la nationale 2 à la pro b l'antichambre
du très haut niveau on va revoir
quelques images philippe vous conservez
quoi comme vraiment quel souvenir précis
de cette période c'est le match de la
montée en pro b
ouais moi j'ai un petit moment qui m'a
marqué c'est le premier match de
l'équipe dans ce palais des sports parce
que ça permettait à l'équipe de prendre
une nouvelle dimension de par la
structure et ça ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
marqué et puis j'ai aussi beaucoup de
bons souvenirs d'une période où il y
avait beaucoup de convivialité on était
vraiment une bande de copains qui a et
qui venait peu à peu dans le
professionnalisme c'est vraiment les
images coach bernois alors c'était les
images de la pro b
enfin pour l'accession en pro b c'était
face à rodez c'est ça vous souvenez bien
je suppose
oui c'est vrai que c'était un petit mas
un match un peu spécial puisque on
attendait le résultat d'un autre match
pendant ce temps là on avait gagné le
match on avait rempli notre contrat on
attendait le résultat d'un autre match
et dès qu'on a eu ce résultat la fin
voilà tout est parti un petit peu dans
tous les sens c'était vraiment la joie
et le bonheur
christophe c'est grâce à des profils
comme fit peser que club a grandi en
sérénité et avec conviction s'il fallait
que la conviction oui parce que je pense
que ces gens là philippe et d'autres
personnes incarne les valeurs du club
elles sont vraiment ancrée et lorsqu'on
président d'un club comme
celui ci on sent réellement en fait tout
l'impact peut avoir ces valeurs qui sont
ancrées et on est porté par ses valeurs
et donc il est bien évident que la
continuité et la fidélité de joueurs
comme philippe c'est absolument
indispensable
et est ce que la dimension familiale et
populaire est toujours présente au club
dans un club professionnel est ce qu'on
arrive à maintenir sa ouais je pense
qu'on arrive à le maintenir parce que il
ya des gens qui suivent l'équipe depuis
depuis longtemps depuis depuis le début
c'est par exemple le gil j le vilain qui
lui en fait est constamment dans tous
les déplacements constamment auprès des
joueurs et
et quand on dérive sur certains points
où on s'écarte un petit peu on est très
très rapidement repositionné par rapport
à ça et on ne l'oublient pas donc ce
club là en fait à réellement en fait à
l'ancrage très fort par rapport à ça il
ya un autre homme qui a compté philips
est le président de l'époque c'était
christophe guérin oui je crois que c'est
un homme qui a été très très important
au sein de ce dispositif et cette
évolution du club je crois qu'à il a
posé les fondations et les fondations
sont très solides et je pense que c'est
ce qui a permis au club de bien évoluer
d'être assis sur quelque chose de solide
oui ça a été un homme marquant de ce
club où la crise oblige le président de
la montée au plus haut niveau
celui qui a fait venir aussi philippe
hervé et qui a connu une finale de coupe
de france de cette époque on peut aussi
retenir deux noms de joueurs ahmed
fellah et et johan blot oui c'était un
meneur
très très impactant j'irai on avait une
grande confiance dans la merde lorsqu'il
prenait les rênes en fait de l'équipe
et puis yoan en fait c'est pareil c'est
quelqu'un qui est je le revois encore
quelquefois sur cette ligne à où l'autre
côté quand ils ont été les trois points
fabuleux et ça a été des moments
d'euphorie extraordinaire et à l'époque
la meilleure influence en pro b
c'était orléans il y avait beaucoup de
supporters bien sûr dans les travées du
palais des sports et il y en a toujours
eu et il y en a des fidèles
plus particulièrement il en homme vous
connaissez bien c'est le maire d'orléans
serge grouard à regarder
oui bah oui j'adore le sport et puis
puis on a une belle équipe avec le lb
ça fait partie effectivement de
l'attractivité du rayonnement de la
ville
le sport la culture nos nouvelles
entreprises la recherche en face et
c'est tout un ensemble depuis
pratiquement qu'ils en étaient au
meilleur niveau français c'est rare
d'avoir une équipe qui se maintient
comme ça dix ans au meilleur niveau on a
joué qui plus est les coupes d'europe et
c'est la première fois qu'on à orléans
une équipe de sport individus de sport
collectif qui est au meilleur niveau
national
magnifique entraîneur avec beaucoup de
sens de la tactique et du jeu et puis en
même temps avec une énergie énorme don
qui il il apportait sa aux joueurs en
plus de son sens du jeu des cui une
craie haute exigence donc philippe on
lui doit énormément bien sûr on
n'existerait pas il est clair que sans
le soutien et la détermination d'un
homme qui essaie revoir le club ne
serait pas au niveau où il est
aujourd'hui parce que je pense que c'est
en 2001 lorsqu'il a annoncé qu'ils
voulaient faire de ce club un grand club
de basket et touché le niveau européen
personne ne le croyait
personne ne le croyait et les gens le
prenaient pour un fou et c'est parfois
grâce à ces hommes là qu'on arrive
effectivement à agrandir
alors depuis l'été dernier vous devez
faire face à la concurrence du football
avec lui et ses eaux qui vient de monter
en ligue 2 comment vous le vivez
cl je vis bien je vis bien parce que
lorsqu'on est monté nous en proie
sachant que le foot est en 2e division
nationale
lorsqu'on est monté en proie en fait
personne n'a subi je dirais des éléments
négatifs par rapport à notre évolution
est aujourd'hui bien le foot est en
train de progresser en train de se
construire
je pense que c'est un jeune club
professionnel qui qui a effectivement
bien entamé la première partie de la
saison et je leur souhaite effectivement
de réussite parce que de réussir parce
que je sais que la route est longue et
la route est loin d'être durable c'est
important et justement vous êtes durable
les finances du club de l'ol b le budget
de 4,4 millions aujourd'hui d'euros
c'est le 11e budget de la pro à vous
êtes dans la moyenne avec une
répartition privé-public intéressante
expliquez nous c'est pas tous les oeufs
dans le même panier
oui en deux fois que c'était en 2004
quand je suis
au niveau des finances publiques qui
représentait plus de 50% aujourd'hui on
est à nettement moins de 30%
et même si effectivement les ports de la
ville a progressé on a réussi en fait à
organiser notre restructuration
financière et nos recettes de manière
importante pour que
on soit à moins de 30% donc on est l'un
des clubs les moins coûteux
proportionnellement en france on ne le
sait pas donc j'aime bien le dire et
merci de me permettre de le dire mais il
est un petit problème dans le projet de
développement du club et n'ya pas il n'y
a toujours pas cette grande salle prévu
il y avait le projet arena qui étaient
enterrés récemment pourtant quand vous
vous déplacez au zénith
bah c'est ça le compte 4800 place c'est
comme il le faut cette salle on est même
à cinq mille à cinq mille places mais on
se déplace moins au zénith ce fait deux
ans qu'on se dépendant de saison se
déplacera pas parce que la difficulté du
zénith c'est qu'il faut tout le monte et
tout démonter et en dehors des coûts de
location qui sont les coups je dirais
normand
nous avons nous les coûts d'organisation
au niveau de la salle ici mais en plus
les coûts d'aménagement dta dire là bas
ça coûte combien un match à ça coûte
entre 35 et 40 mille euros chaque match
donc c'est un handicap important et
lorsque nous sommes un club qui voulons
avoir un équilibre financier sain et
bien c'est très difficile de ne pas être
en capacité difficile de mettre en place
ce type de l'événement de manière
régulière
philippe depuis que le projet arena est
tombé à l'eau où en est-on précisément
je crois que vous faire partie d'une
commission qui réfléchit sur des
solutions
oui complètement tout à l'heure je vous
préciserai que le club avait changé de
dimension à partir du moment où nous
étions arrivés au palais des sports
et je crois que le club pour passer un
cap aura besoin d'une nouvelle structure
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une gamme via
des éléments qui sont empreints action
en gestation ont réfléchi à tout ça
c'est à dire ces voix là c'est à dire
qu'on a bien conscience de la situation
des études vont être menées on a des
orientations et dès qu'on aura plus
d'éléments par rapport à ça on vous en
dira un peu plus mais je crois que on
est bien conscient de cette situation et
on va tout faire pour que le club
bénéficie à un moment ou à un autre
d'une structure qui lui permettent
d'évoluer
on souhaite que ce projet aboutisse il
est très important pour les 20
prochaines années j'ai envie de dire il
est évidemment pratiquement vital enfin
je pense qu'on ne pourra pas rester au
plus haut niveau tel qu'on l'est
aujourd'hui
si en fait le club ne peut pas
progresser dans ses recettes
d'autant plus que les finances publiques
on sait qu'elles vont baisser donc c'est
vraiment absolument vitale sont plus
avoir un équipement en adéquation avec
notre niveau très important pour le club
très important pour les supporters
certains sont venus aujourd'hui on les
remercie notamment les membres des magic
sur les supporters toujours fidèle on va
retrouver justement arnaud en compagnie
du président de la section amateur de
l'ulb
oui tout à fait benoît je suis avec
philippe la non qui est président de la
section amateur on parlait de chiffres à
l'instant orléans est le dixième club de
france en nombre d'adhérents seul cholet
et nancy sont devant vous je crois au
niveau des du nombre d'adhérents
tout à fait donc depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années orléans et entre le 7e
et 10e rangs
donc au niveau du championnat de france
en effectif là quarante équipes à peu
près 500 adhérents 60 entraîneur
donc compagne acteurs est donc vivement
des trois quarts d'un garçon à cartes
filles c'est pas dur de gérer tout ce
tous ses adhérents
si c'est une grosse machine va à peu
près wadia 300000 euros de budget que me
parler argent donc c'est très compliqué
très compliqué surtout au niveau des
déplacements au niveau de la logistique
ce qu'il va être dur aussi c'est d'être
l'équipe à battre c'est dire que quand y
ait une vision holistique qui se déplace
dans un petit village il ya 150
personnes qui vous attendent
oui c'est plus facile à gérer parce que
le milieu sportif sur le terrain c'est
plus facile que tout ce qui est avant ou
après le match
donc après ça se joue sans problème ont
donc oui et déco comment comment gérez
vous pouviez donc c'est assez compliqué
à gérer mais ce qui est plus compliqué
j'imagine si qu'aujourd'hui vous ne
pouvez que stagner peu plus grandir
entourés peut-être grandir mais il
faudrait encore une salle où des moyens
importants dont on attire beaucoup de
personnes ça c'est un problème parce que
leur nom d'orléans donc il ya beaucoup
de gens qui veulent venir jouer respecte
ici et aussi encadré mais
malheureusement il ya une limite donc on
s'était fixé après 500 parce que là on
est déjà au summum
on peut pas faire plus chic en soit
voilà merci philippe lannes on est pas
pour accompagner toutes ses équipes
notamment les professionnels il ya les
supporters il existe depuis 15 ans les
magic cube d'orléans le club de
supporters
christine cirque et 1 et vincent le giro
ont assisté à un match à leurs côtés
pour la rue
l'ol b indissociable des magic sub clubs
de supporters fidèles dans son rôle de
sixième homme à deux heures du coup
d'envoi déjà du monde dans le kop on
papote on s'informe on prépare la
rencontre
les magic support vu le jour au début
des années 2000 avant même à l'accession
du club en pro b les gens on est était
en attente plus ou moins quand même
qu'ils intègrent des supporters c'est
vrai qu'entre nous ça faisait plusieurs
pas mal de temps qu'on commence à en
parler un peu ça s'est concrétisé comme
ça grâce à l'entraîneur de l'époque et
l'aventuré continue nouvelle saison
nouvel équipement validée par le
président lui-même
bientôt le match les joueurs terminent
l'échauffement les supporters s'éveille
métamorphose
mais normalement dans deux minutes à peu
près devrait arriver donc là déjà on va
là on va commencer à chauffer un petit
peu à les accueillir sur l'autel sur le
terrain pour leur faire voir qu'on est
là et puis là le petit à petit on va
faire chauffer l'ambiance dans le vif du
sujet la rencontre est lancée les magic
sup aussi avec tambours et trompettes
sans oublier l'hygiaphone le petit plus
de l'année mais c'est d'abord nous en
servir pour un maximum de bruit pour
essayer d'arranger le public mais ya pas
beaucoup de résultats mais ce que les
joueurs nous entende et ça ça valait
faire bouger plus même s'il bouge plus
ça ne suffit pas forcément l'ol b
largement dominé qu'importe les magic
sud continuent à donner de la voix
ces deux plats de supporter l'équipe est
là jusqu'au bout de joux dans les bons
dans les mauvais moments fin de match
défaite déception mais les magic sud
sont là une soixantaine pour l'instant
en attendant mieux que vous avez dépassé
la centaine pour le moment de l'épopée
européenne
je suis avec la mascotte et avec jean
noël du club des supporters alors j'en
ai l'air très rapidement supporters de
lbc le voyant découvrir la france bah
oui c'est ça c'est un peu grâce au
déplacement avons fait avec les magic
succès parcourir du la france allait aux
quatre coins de la france et c'est vrai
que en plus des matchs de basket fiba on
découvre les villes ou dans lesquels on
va t'en remercie jean noël merci et
bonne fin d'émission et noir merci
beaucoup arno christophe s'est
malheureusement bientôt déjà l'heure de
se quitter s'est passé très très vite
rapidement les objectifs de la saison
que vous avez fixé à françois perronnet
son groupe déjà le premier objectif
c'était déjà de construire une bonne
équipe et je suis certain que l'équipe
est bonne et avec des éléments
intéressants
après le deuxième objectif c'est sur le
plan sportif
dans un premier temps participé à leader
scop c'est la troisième année qu'on
pourrait de suite participé à 7 10
heures scott et puis faire les play-offs
parce que ça fait deux ans qu'on n'y est
plus donc voilà on aimerait bien pouvoir
faire les play-offs et puis après on
verra comment ça évoluera par rapport à
cette compétition là on vous suivra bien
sûr tout au long de cette saison et dès
mardi 1 face aux morts en match de
clôture de la 4e journée du championnat
pro à le match où la mairie d'orléans a
décidé de faire une opération spéciale
de soutien avec les nouvelles couleurs
du club jaune et grenat arnaud merci
beaucoup nous avons accompagné merci
aussi à toutes les équipes techniques
éditoriales merci à florent thibault de
l'eau est élevé on se retrouve très
bientôt sur france 3 centre ont d'autres
opérations spéciales et bien sûr pour on
l'espère suivre encore l'orléans loiret
basket pour 20 belle nouvelle année à
très bientôt sur france 3 va
n'est pas
mais
une mi temps
et c'est tout